all right many people who want to get on
with me today i want to hear from
some of them let's go first here to
marta from miami florida marta what is
on your mind today
hello hello yes i can oh
what else are you thinking about i'm i
live in miami florida
marta you're cutting in and out all
right so so we you're i can barely hear
you i heard you live in miami and then
you immediately cut out
so most of my family is cuban-american
and they keep using the argument that
biden is a communist and he's a
socialist
and i just want to know what can i say
to them or if you have like a good
article you can recommend
just so i can like but that argument
listen i have not seen
anybody seriously be able to answer the
question
which biden policy is a socialist
policy so i'd be curious if you were to
say
okay let's let's actually examine that
what biden policy is a socialist policy
usually that falls apart and then they
move on to a different argument which
maybe would be easier to deal with
yeah because i tell them i'm like you
know it's not it's not going to be like
that they're like no it's going to be
like cuba and we're going to be you know
struggling for food listen
i mean i say to them was it like cubo
when barack obama was president for
eight years
because joe biden was the vice president
if it wasn't like cuba during those
eight years why would it be like that
under joe biden
yeah and then they bring up you know the
whole cuban missile crisis
and kennedy and it's just uh what is
that happening joe biden what
you know i think in a lot of these here
what you're getting to marta
is that in a lot of these situations
it's not really about
you explaining the truth it's about just
coming up with something to say so they
can perpetuate their own
misunderstandings
and you might i mean it could go that
way it could go
biden's a socialist and you say well
what's one socialist policy
they say well it's just it's gonna
become like cuba and then you would say
well
was it like cuba when obama was
president and then they would say yeah
but look at what kennedy did during the
cuban missile crisis now we're 50 years
ago
right it's they don't really want to
know anything and sometimes you have to
just acknowledge that
yeah that's basically been the exact
argument for months and months and
months
that i i don't envy you marta and you
know for people who are calling in and
may not know
the american uh hispanic community
is a very left-wing community in total
but the the most conservative
sub-section
of latin americans is cuban-americans
and it is usually this reflexive
anti-castro thing that the ones who came
to the u.s
were against the castro regime they
associate the castro regime with
democrats
why i don't know and you end up in
situations like marta's situation
okay thank you very much all right great
to hear from you marta appreciate uh
appreciate the call one of our sponsors
is privacy.com they're giving you five
dollars when you sign up for their
completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy
something online or on the phone instead
of actually using your real credit card
number
the privacy app and the browser plug-in
let you give each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create
out of thin air it'll even autofill the
card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want
privacy also offers a ten dollar a month
plan that gives you one percent cash
back and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a 25
a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up
at privacy.com slash pacman